- What our job is as an
entrepreneur is to recognize
that this initial thing
in our head is a bad idea,
and that the only way we're
going to figure out why it's a bad
idea is by trying it, by
starting it, by doing something,
by testing something,
or selling something or making something.
Here is how to start doing it
does not need to raise money.
You don't need to co-founder.
You don't need all that stuff.
You just need to be clever
and creative to figure out
a way to quickly, easily,
and cheaply try your idea
out in the real world.
And if you can master that
one skill, it's the skill
of starting all the rest of it is easier.
- And there he is. I love
it. The horns. I love it.
Mr. Mark Randolph in the house,
man, what to say about you?
I mean, I guess see the, the
founder, co-founder of Netflix,
but advisor, entrepreneur,
nature enthusiast.
He's got an awesome book and a
podcast that will never work.
And we're going to have some fun
together. Welcome aboard, man.
- Well, thanks Evan. Pleasure
to be here. You forgot.
Humble and lovable, you know, kind
- Of like, let's, can we, let's
dive into that a little bit
because you know, I was, as
I was watching your stuff,
obviously everybody says,
well, co-founder of Netflix,
you've done so much since then.
- Yeah, it was a, it was a long time ago.
I'm not going to sit in
my laurels after that.
You know, it, it's, it's,
it's, it's a compulsion thing.
You can't sit still. I
mean, so many people think,
oh my gosh, if I ever have
a big successful company,
I am so done.
I'm going to play golf. I'm going to go
sit in the beach someplace.
But you know, the exact
same things that lead you
to work hard on a startup,
make it incapable,
make you incapable of sitting still.
You just want to go
back and do that thing.
It's so fun figuring
something out, you know?
- And then in looking at all
the startups you've either
created or invested in or helped in,
and then just the other
things that you're proud of
with your, with your,
you know, work in nature
or even just staying with the
same wife for all these years
and have, having a
relationship with your kids
and like all the stuff that
so many entrepreneurs maybe struggle with.
If you, if you fast forward
to, you know, 30 years forward
and you're still doing this,
what do you hope is the
introduction that you
get on a show like this?
- Oh, God, that's a great question, Evan.
You know, I guess I, what
I, I guess I, what I'd love
to say is that I'd love you
say if Evan, you said, Hey,
I'd like to bring up Mark Randolph.
Listen, he had a whole bunch of
entrepreneurial stuff he did.
But fundamentally, what's incredible is
how many people he's helped do
the same things that he did.
You know, he, I can point to 50
or 60 people who've all were
just sitting there on their
butt and he inspired them to get going
and actually take that idea
and do something about it.
If I could do that, I would look back
and say, those last 30 years were awesome.
- All right, I'm taking
notes. I'll see you in 2050.
We'll, we'll be doing it in holograms,
beaming into each other's living rooms.
That'll be fine. 'cause I, I
think just in watching some
of your setback, I think, I
think people don't honestly even
give you enough credit for
all the new stuff you've done.
It's just always, oh, well,
he co-founded Netflix.
Let's talk about your,
your book and your show.
That will never work. I
think it's probably one
of the biggest problems that
entrepreneurs face is they get,
they're the crazy ones, you know,
and then they get this
idea and they go downstairs
and they tell their family,
or they tell their friends.
And, and that's the first
response is, mark, you're crazy.
That'll never work.
- Yeah. You got to take,
you got to take that
as a good sign, Evan.
'cause you see, when, if
you, if you actually do that,
you wake up in the morning
and you come rushing down
and you tell your spouse or
your roommates or whoever that,
and they go, well, that'll ever work.
What it means is you've
probably stumbled onto something
which actually hasn't been tried before,
because that's what you're looking for.
- So do you use that as a trigger that,
that if other people say
that, that means I have
to do it because they said that
- No, it not in some inspiration,
not in like a, oh, okay,
I'm going to, I'm going
to prove them wrong.
Right. It's not like, it's not like that.
It's more recognizing that
it doesn't mean anything.
It's a natural part of
the process. Of course.
Have I heard that? That will
never work. Oh, there it is.
Okay. Let's just keep going.
You know, because the
reality is, what I've learned
and by 40 years as an entrepreneur, is
that there is no such
thing as a good idea,
which I know is like contrary to
what you always hear in like,
in brainstorming sessions
and, oh no, there's no such thing.
That's a bad idea. Let's bull.
There's, they're all bad ideas.
Because what our job is as an
entrepreneur is to recognize
that this initial thing
in our head is a bad idea.
And that the only way we're
going to figure out why it's a bad
idea is by trying it, by
starting it, by doing something,
by testing something, or selling something
or making something that we
have to go through that process.
And that what so many
people do is they're looking
for the good idea.
They're waiting for the one
where they tell their friends,
they all go, that's amazing,
but it doesn't mean anything.
It's not a good idea, I promise.
Whatever your idea is,
it's not a good idea.
The whole way an entrepreneur does this.
Every single successful
startup that you know about
is not successful doing the thing
that entrepreneur
originally had the idea for.
It's because they started realized
how stupid the original idea was.
And listen, we can go
back and talk about it,
but Netflix was no different
and said, oh, okay, that didn't work.
Let's what I try next. What do I try next?
And then if you're lucky,
through this period of meandering
and trying lots of stuff,
maybe you'll eventually land in the thing
that lo and behold, it does work.
But it only happens if
you take that first step
and go, I don't care whether
you think it's a good idea
or a bad idea, I'm going to try it anyway.
And let's see what happens.
- It's fun looking at some
of these big businesses
and looking at the original business plan.
- Yeah. Because
- It's just so off compared to
what they actually
became most of the time.
- Well, what's cool is that you,
when you actually get a chance
to talk about this process,
because what I learned, listen
back at the very beginning,
even with Netflix, you know,
so a journalist comes up
and goes, oh, mark, where
did the idea come from?
And, and if you, you'll launch
into that, well, actually,
there's a bunch of people involved.
We tried this. And you
know, their eyes glaze over.
They, they want to go on
to the next question.
And so pretty quickly you
fall back to the, okay,
I'm going to come up with a one-liner.
You know? Oh, it's because
of a late being movie.
And it's, it's fine.
It's emotionally true.
It resonates, but it's
not how it really works.
You know, we love that. Listen,
I'm no, I'm no different.
You'll love that glorified epiphany moment
where the light bulb goes
off and it's all clear.
You know, what's the, what's
the one about, you know, the,
the two, the guys can't, in San Francisco,
they can't make the rent.
So they go, let's put a air mattress
down in the spare bedroom.
And boom, like, there's Airbnb,
or I guess the other one is, you know,
I can't get a cab on New Year's Eve,
and then boom, there's Uber
or Lathe a movie, and
boom, there's Netflix.
And no, it does not work that way.
It works by going, I have this idea.
And then someone else goes,
yeah, but how about this?
Someone else goes, how
about this? Then we try it.
Oh crap, that didn't work.
Let's go this direction,
let's go this direction.
It's, it's messy. It's incomplete.
It has lots of people involved,
but when it comes together,
that's the most thrilling
thing thing in the world.
- What I love about your message
is you are pushing people
to action and giving them
permission to mini fail
and not to work out.
- Oh, yeah. I love two things you said.
I mean, certainly I love
the permission to fail.
Fail because fail, listen,
I, it's human nature
that we don't want to look like asses.
You know, everyone who's
learned a foreign language knows
that you don't learn anything
unless you open your mouth
and you're willing to sound
like you're a 5-year-old,
even when you're like a 40 years old going
and ordering coffee someplace.
But listen, starting companies
or doing anything, which is a new
or a dream you have requires
the mini part of it.
This is practice. You know?
Now if I'm starting a business, yeah, I,
I can raise large amounts
of money, I can marshal lots
of people, but that's only
because I've been doing it for 40 years.
But my very first efforts were tiny.
You know, they were starting clubs,
they were doing mag little
Passion Project magazine stuff.
I mean, I, I made these mistakes
at a very, very small scale
where I begin to learn
how do you make decisions?
How do you get the
confidence to move forward?
So yeah, many failure is the key.
Don't think, you know,
you have this idea, okay,
I've got to raise money,
I've got to get a computer science degree,
I've got to finish school.
I've got to quit my day job.
I, listen, I've heard every
single possible excuse.
And they're all, you know,
the, the trick is mini.
So keep your day job.
Do something at night, start a website,
sell something door to door.
Try it out in your friends.
That's the way that that does,
that is the path that leads to
being successful as an entrepreneur.
If that's something that
you're interested in
- When you're, when
you're talking to somebody
or coaching them, they've
got all these excuses
that they believe, 'cause
they're plausible reasons.
It's not some super made up one.
But underneath is really just fear.
How do you get them to see the fear
and then move into action mode?
- You know, it's,
you're touching on something
which is much bigger, which is
that the advice that sometimes
you get from people like
myself and from, well-meaning
entrepreneurs is a
platitude in some ways.
You know, don't be afraid
to start. Well, thank you.
You know, start small. Well, thank you.
There's a real trick
and there's an art to saying,
how do I figure out how
to test my ideas cheaply
or quickly or easily?
And, and pardon me here for
doing the plug in a sense,
but it's the reason I did my podcast not
as interviews with big,
successful entrepreneurs.
My podcast is not baiting people
and going, here's this person I,
because people like you do it
so much better than I do it.
But it's because I wanted people to see
how I literally took someone
who was struggling with an idea
and how to test their idea
and walk them through the process.
These are mentoring sessions
where I'll take someone
who goes, I have this cool idea
and I've been dreaming about it.
And I go, let's cut the,
let's right now, talk about
how you can get started tomorrow.
And we then brainstorm with their idea
what could they could do to
begin that learning process
that does not take money,
does not take weeks,
does not take a co-founder
that they can just do tomorrow.
Listen, I do, we have,
we have, let's see, you have two seconds.
I'll give you an example.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Go for it.
So this is one, one
young woman, I, I, I met.
She had an idea, everyone's got ideas
and she, her idea was she wanted
to do this peer-to-peer
clothing sharing service.
Basically. She goes, look,
I have all these blouses.
I don't wear that. I have
friends of all these clothes.
Wouldn't be cool if there
was a way, not just for us,
but for everybody to come on this app
and pick out other people's clothing.
And, and I go, alright,
I go secretly I'm going,
it's a bad idea, but it it, it's good.
But who know, who knows?
It's could be a great idea.
No one knows anything. Let's
figure out how to quickly
and easily test this.
And she was going, how do I raise money?
How do I hire people in
Kazakhstan to build the app?
All the crap. Well, when I
graduate, oh, no, no, no, no.
Listen, do you have a piece of paper?
He goes, yeah, of course
you have a piece of paper.
You have a Sharpie. Yes,
I I have a magic marker.
I go, great. So what I want
you to do is write on the piece
of paper, write down, do
you want to borrow my clothes?
Question mark, knock exclamation point.
And I want you to tape that to
the outside of your dorm room
as soon as we finish with this call.
And I go, 'cause what's
going to happen is two things.
One, no one's going to knock. Okay, great.
You've learned something
important right there
that this dream, there
are thousands of people
who want to borrow your
clothes, is false or better.
Someone knocks fantastic.
Now you're going to
find out the next thing.
They're going to come in your room
and you're going to see are
there problems with size,
with taste, with fit?
Now, let's say those things work.
Now you're going to find
something else, which is,
how do you feel when
that favorite blouse ears
comes back stained?
Or that you have to now have dry cleaning
or et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
And you're going to find out
all those things tomorrow
and you're going to find them out
with a pen and a piece of paper.
That is the process that
an entrepreneur goes on.
And being able to walk someone through,
how do I get started?
Makes it real. When you say
stop thinking and start doing,
but it goes here is how to start doing.
It does not need to raise money.
You don't need to co-founder.
You don't need all that stuff.
You just need to be clever
and creative to figure out
a way to quickly, easily,
and cheaply try your idea
out in the real world.
And that's, you know, I do that
a lot on the podcast as well
as all the other stuff
people bump into problems
with co-founders, how to
find work life balance.
How tovo my idea's going to get stolen.
I mean, all these things that
everyone thinks they're the
only one wrestling with, in fact, lots
of people are struggling with,
- Talk about the move
from building businesses,
which you're still obviously doing,
but to advising, investing, mentorship,
even the, even the book,
the book you can kind of see
behind you that will
never work. There it is
- Guys.
They'll pick it up. This, oh
what, oh, I didn't even know
how, how'd that get there?
- There it is. The podcast,
same name that will never work.
So like, there's a shift from hey,
just being in the operations
to now wanting to help inspire,
motivate, mentor, coach,
whatever you want to call it.
Other entrepreneurs. What?
Talk about that shift.
- Alright, at the risk
of being sound like a complete ass here,
I learned this on Richard
Branson's private island.
I was that for a, a
great intro to a story.
So it's quite literal.
Seriously, I, I do some speaking
and I was invited by his charity to come
and work, do a, a brief
presentation at this event.
And the event was called
Finding Your Purpose.
And I'm going, purpose
schur, I'm just going to go
and do my bit.
And then my wife and I'll
spend three days on the beach.
And it turns out these
were all of conference
for very successful female business owners
who had achieved tremendous success.
And were going, what? Now
what do I do with this?
And so I went and my whole
presentation then was,
listen, how do you take ideas?
You have? And then how
do you quickly, cheaply,
easily find out whether
they're valid or not?
So I went and did my thing
and I go, I'm going to sit around
and see what this purpose
thing is all about.
And I was totally sucked in.
And like three hours later, my
wife goes, where the hell are you?
And I go, sit down, sit down.
And, and then she's drawn in.
The point is, I realized I
was going, what's my purpose?
You know, listen, I can
now get up and do a speech
and I'll get 10,000 people
to listen for an hour,
but what's the point?
And I realized, and here
it comes, the punchline.
The point is that in 40
years, an entrepreneur,
I've learned all this stuff
about how to take an idea
that's in your head and make it real.
And more importantly, those same tips
and tricks don't just work
for businesses, they work
for anybody who has some
crazy idea they want to try.
And that moment I go,
that's my purpose, is
to help unlock people.
To give them the whack
on the side of the head.
Give 'em the tough love that says you,
if you have this idea, if you
have something you want to do,
if you want to be an entrepreneur,
then for God's sake,
let me help you start doing it.
It's been this amazing thing for me
and that guided now how, why
and how do I accept speaking invitations?
It's for that, it's why
I wrote the book to try
and put this into a written form about
how these things came
into practice in my life
and how they could in other people's life.
It's why I started the podcast, was to try
and show people to mentor people live
so other people could, could listen in.
So I, I still need my own fix.
I still work
with other early stage
entrepreneurs in a very deep way,
which is not altruistic.
I mean, yeah, I try and help
them be successful in their
business, but I'm trying to
get that fixed for myself
as well, where I get
to sit around the table
with the super smart people
and solve really interesting problems.
And it's wonderful that it
works out for both of us.
- One of the big things
that I've been pushing a lot
of my bigger friends, like Brendan Bachar
and those guys, I think one
of the biggest opportunities
for, for this year, next
year is live coaching.
Where, where most people
who are making YouTube videos
are just talking direct
to camera and saying, here are
the eight ways to do X, y, z.
Which is great. But I think
the biggest opportunity if
you're good at coaching,
is to actually show
me you coaching.
Like, let me see somebody
come in with a bunch
of problems and learn new beliefs.
And then if you're good at
what you do, you unravel them
and hold a cow and even see it that way.
I love the premise of the show.
Why is it not a video show?
- Well listen those, you see
this here, that that's a sign
that I'm 63 years old and I listen,
but I'm a learner guy and I
push myself very, very hard
to try and stay fluent.
So you walk before you run
and I go, I'm going to learn
this podcasting gig.
Because I think it is a
very, I think it's exactly
what you said, everyone's going,
mark God, you should do a podcast.
You know, everybody, you
should get on the, you know,
founders, you should do a
version of how I built this.
Someone's done how I built this.
And they do it way better than me.
I go, I want to coach, I want
people to see how I coach.
I want them to listen
in. So I wish I'd talked
to you like five years
ago 'cause it would've
saved you some time.
But I'm learning that mechanism.
How do you make this
engaging and interesting
and have the right guests so that people
recognize they're not alone and they learn
and they're inspired, but they're
also entertained to some degree.
But right now I'm doing
the, the simple version,
which is I'm just dumping it
onto dumping it onto YouTube.
I could learn so much from
you about how to then make
that more engaging so you can watch them.
But right now it's just watching
two heads on a Zoom screen.
Hmm. But there's got to be a more
powerful way and we will get there.
I'm also doing live coaching
on Clubhouse now every Tuesday
at 5:00 PM Pacific time.
I do a hour long version
of coaching real time,
but of course it's audio.
But my whole process now we'll
go meta on you here, is that
when I want to launch
something, again, I do not
go think about it.
I don't go, oh, what a great
idea and dream of this.
Incredible. Rather we'll have a studio,
imagine will be on TV
and go let, I'm going to figure a quick,
cheap and easy way to start.
And for me, for the podcast,
I'm just going to begin
recording the mentoring calls.
I do anyway, and I did that
for about a year making all these mistakes
of figuring out what makes it good.
And then I go, okay, I've learned enough
that I'm now I'm ready to
embarrass myself in public.
And I talk about that.
I do this stuff un fully formed
because I'd rather collide it
with reality early and learn that way.
I have a team of people who help me
and I'm always going, stop debating this.
Let's just try it next week. It's so fun.
I mean even the, the the, the
clubhouse was this brand new
medium that no one, no one
can say, oh Mark, listen,
I've been doing real time audio
clubhouse type talk for 20.
No you haven't. The thing
launched in Fri April last year,
we're all getting to
figure it out together.
It's fantastic. So you are
right, it's incredibly promising,
but, and I, I'll get there
and you'll get to watch me
totally mess it up in, in person.
- Well I'm happy to help.
I'm happy to help anytime along the way.
I just think because
of where you want to go,
YouTube is the only place for
your content list forever.
And because what you're doing
is so timeless in five years,
10 years, 20 years, that interview that
that coaching session
you did is still there,
is still valuable, is still a memory
and, and a lesson for people.
The next generation,
even though, you know,
something like Clubhouse,
it just disappears.
It's just a moment in time.
What we're doing here is meta.
Like this is an Instagram
live video that I'm going to cut
and put to my YouTube channel
and it'll get a couple
hundred thousand views
on the YouTube side.
This is an easy way to do coaching.
- Yeah.
- We're just swapped.
You go on top and your, your
student comes underneath
and then you show up and coach them
and turn into a YouTube video.
- No, it's fantastic.
Yeah, I I'm a, you know,
I I started off this little,
this little piece if I swat you
about this and that, I'm old
and it didn't come naturally
in me, but IIII love it
and I loved how quickly
you can iterate using these
mediums and you're absolutely right.
Even just watching how we're
get as meta, I'm watching
how we're doing this, I'm going
this, this could be a very,
very powerful way, a
powerful way to do it.
'cause I, as with the,
at first when I was doing
the podcast, you go,
the podcast is nice because it's non-live.
I mean, it's live and
I'm doing a real call,
but I can make a mistake
and you know, I can, the dog can jump up
and knock over the microphone
and I can go back and cut that out later.
But doing clubhouse,
although it's not preserved,
what's wonderful is it's
giving me the confidence
to walk the wire that someone can call in.
And I've now become comfortable
that I can almost always find some way
to help them move a little
bit further on their
journey, on the spot.
Which means doing something
like we're doing now.
It might be a perfect way to do that.
Let people watch it
live, listen to it live,
but then begin to say, we can save this.
Yeah, here you go. This is
a coaching session from you and me.
- Well, yeah, well there you
go. But I think I, Benny,
I Benny, you're the guy for that
because you're not the, your
message is not be perfect.
Don't launch until
everything's got, you know,
everything's ordered and
everything has to be fancy edited.
You're the, you're the,
I'm going to do it,
it's going to be messy.
I'll figure it as we go
and, oh, my dog barked.
Okay, next time I'm going to
put him in the kitchen.
You know, like, like that's
part of the learnings.
- It's one of the things I learned about
the social media piece too.
Like Gary V actually was
beating me on me about that.
And he goes, you know this,
if you have an idea for,
stop thinking about how
good the presentation
is, just grab your phone.
I don't care where you are,
I don't how noisy you are,
what you're wearing, whether you're shaved
or not, just talk into the phone
and say the idea, get it out there.
'cause that's 98% of the value
and the production stuff is great,
but you by only saying
I'm going to do a hundredth
of aish content 'cause
I can get that perfect.
You totally missed the point.
And I think that's kind
what you're saying too.
It's, it's very startupy
and I should do the exact,
I should walk the walk that way too.
- I love it. Well, we got got, we've all
- Looking together. We're all looking
- Together.
Yeah, this is great. I love it. So we,
we got, we got what a minute left.
What, what's the final message you have
for my audience on Instagram, on YouTube?
- Listen, as, as hard as
this is to believe, I'm not
that much different than
most people out there.
You know, I'm certainly not smarter.
Maybe I work a little bit harder,
but I have an undergraduate
degree in geology of all things.
So I'm not like, I'm, I'm super guy.
I've just learned the
value of trying stuff.
I've gotten over my fear of starting,
I've gotten over my hesitancy to do things
that people say don't work.
And if you can master that
one skill, it's a skill
of starting all the rest of it is easier.
So if I can say one thing, it's,
it's stop thinking and start feeling.
- I love it. Mark Randolph,
everybody, the book
and the podcast are both
called, that Will Never Work.
Stay tuned to the YouTube
channel coming soon.
We'll link all that stuff up for you,
YouTube and description below.
Appreciate you, man.
Thanks. Thanks for the time.
Thanks for coming on the
wisdom, the permission
to be stupid,
and I, I think you're onto
something big here. Fantastic.
- Thanks for the opportunity.
- Much love. Take care.
- If you want to see the top
10 I did on Mark Randolph,
check it out right there next to me.
I think you'll love
it. Continue to believe
and I'll see you there.
- You can't tell by thinking about it,
that there's really only
way to figure out whether a,
it's a good idea or a bad idea.
And that is to do it.